hi I'm Eroica nada i work for la nación
is an argentine national newspaper and i
chose to answer yet bhinder question
that in America has one of the highest
youth unemployment rates in the world
how can Latin America increase
opportunities for young people well it's
a long answer the short one should be
education we should try to educate more
informal to the youngest population from
the region but also remember that also
everybody should try to do it by their
own now it's difficult but the
interpreter soul should be there and you
should try you should take an aim and
shoot and try to do it by yourself you
can you can well let's do it again the
first one is education and its capacity
organize yourself and try to get in form
and try to develop skills and further
Latin American governments and also
civil society and also international
forest could help could invest and could
develop funding and scholarships for
is not